[Music]
[Applause]
you everyone for being here and bless
you for choosing to come to a talk about
boxplots and so I'd like to tell you a
story about a bug in ggplot twos
boxplots
but this talk is not really about
boxplots because it's really about how
to go about understanding and fixing
bugs when you're faced with a problem
that you don't know how to solve and so
I'm hoping that the strategy that I'll
share that helped me solve this
particular bug will be one that you can
take and maybe use in your own coding
work whether that's working on our
packages or data analysis code or any
other situation that you might find
yourself in so a while back someone
opened this issue on the github repo for
ggplot2
they said when I try to produce colors
or box plots with colors depending on a
categorical variable these appear
overlapping if VAR width is set to true
so if you're not familiar with box plots
and ggplot VAR width is an option that
lets the boxes vary in width depending
on the number of points they represent
which can be really useful if you have
very imbalanced classes in your data
that you want to represent that some of
these boxes are representing fewer
points than others so I was working as a
ggplot2 intern at the time and I was
mainly supposed to be focusing on other
aspects of the code base but I saw this
issue come in and I thought this should
be straightforward to fix like I'll just
knock this one out really quick
but we've got about 18 minutes of this
talk slot left so you can probably guess
that that isn't how things actually
turned out in fact it was a way more
complicated bug than I had really
anticipated and I ended up having to
write an entirely new algorithm to place
boxes in box plots and and working on
this was probably the deepest that I had
ever gone into trying to fix just one
seemingly simple bug and I learned a lot
about how to approach this process in
doing so so when I'm trying to fix a bug
in some code I like to let myself be
guided by three questions how do I know
what the bug is first then how do I fix
it and then how do I know when I'm done
fixing it and by by answering these
questions I find I can keep myself a
little bit on track and that there are
some specific strategies that I can use
in answering each so before you can go
about fixing a bug you have to know what
the bug is and the best way to figure
that out is to start by isolating the
problem so at this point you're not
necessarily even trying to think about
what the cause of the problem is but
rather just trying to pin down exactly
when it happens and the best way to
convey this is through a minimal
reproducible example or a reference a
rep Rex should be the minimal code and
data necessary to produce the problem
that you're seeing and the minimal part
is really important here because if you
have thousands of rows of data and lots
of custom plot themes there's a lot of
distractions and it's hard to tell
what's really relevant to the problem at
hand
so paring it down it can really help
isolate the problem and often can turn
up can can help you figure out what is
causing it through that process then the
reproducible part is important so that
you or someone else can know if you
fixed it if the problem if you're not
sure when the problem occurs you can't
make it happen reliably it's hard to
know if it's really been solved so the
req Rex package by jenny/brian makes it
really easy to produce these nice
standalone copy/paste able rep Rex's and
it can even do things like embed figures
into the output and fortunately the
person who reported this issue provided
a reference of
problem so they did this step for me of
isolating the problem so without any
extraneous detail they identified
exactly when the problem occurs when
boxes have variable widths they overlap
if they don't have variable width they
don't and I really like this reference
because every piece of code that is in
it is necessary to producing this
problem they also gave an example of the
case where the problem doesn't occur
when we have these uniform width boxes
you can see that they get moved side to
side and they don't overlap so that's
what we're that's what we're aiming for
so once you've isolated when the problem
occurs it's time to start digging into
the cause and to do that you need to
kind of follow the data through its
journey to the point where the problem
occurs with plotting code in particular
this can be sort of challenging because
a lot is going on within ggplot2 to turn
a data frame that you provide into a
plot and at the time that I worked on
this I was not familiar with all of the
steps that were happening so I wasn't
even sure really where to start looking
but this was sort of my thought process
so looking at the code that was reported
I can see that in the buggy version of
the plot we get this morning message
warning position dodge requires
non-overlapping X intervals and this is
a little bit confusing to me because
like yeah the whole point is that these
are overlapping and we don't want them
to like we're not trying to have
overlapping X intervals here but I can
latch on to this position dodged and
sort of try to figure out what is
happening around there that is probably
contributing to this problem since
that's in the warning message so I'm
gonna try to find position dodge and see
if I can figure out what it's meant to
do and to do this I need to search into
the ggplot2 code base which I'm have a
copy of locally I could search within
the folder of code and find it but
honestly a lot of time I'm searching on
github and so I'll type in position
dodge and find where it's find where
it's located and see where I go from
there so then I go through the function
reading it line by line
and seeing when the function that I'm on
may be calling some other function that
I don't know and sort of repeating that
process of just reading the code reading
the comments hoping that I can make some
sense of it hopefully the comments in
code are clear enough that it's possible
to do this and in this case I was able
to figure out just by reading that
there's sort of this pathway that the
data goes through from position dodge to
capital P position Dodge to a function
called collide and then pass dodge and
it's and it appeared that those last two
were the ones kind of controlling the
most about how these boxes were being
placed so at a high level what collide
does is that it gets information about
the boxes before they've been moved side
to side so the when you have these
overlap you it gets these overlapping
boxes looks for the overlap and then
sends all of the overlapping boxes to
pass dodge which will shrink them down
and move them side-by-side and so the
boxes sort of look like this figure when
they arrive to collide and then in
groups they get sent to pass dodge so
one will go and then the next will go
and poss - is the one that moves them
side to side so that's that's helpful
but now I want to see okay what's wrong
with the variable-width boxes that's
making this not happen I want to explore
what these functions are actually doing
and look at what data they see so I can
try to get more insight into this so I
I'm very regretful that I wrote our code
for many years without using debug or
trace or a lot of the really helpful
tools for debugging that are built into
our so debug is one that I'll give an
example of right now and I use it all
the time now because it lets you enter
into the function that you're interested
in and step through it and see all of
the data that it's passed and see all of
the transformations that it does as if
you were in a regular our console so
through calling debug on the collide
function I can enter into collide
and and that's what this message here is
saying debugging in collide and I can
then view the data that's being passed
to the data argument of collide so this
is roughly what the data looks like for
a standard box plot when all the boxes
are the same size the data that I've
removed some columns to simplify it but
there's basically one row per box that
gives information about what x position
it's centered at the start and end
points of the boxes horizontally the
x-min and x-max
and then in the data that i removed
there's also the y position the color
and so forth so if you had just an empty
plot this would be all the information
that you would need to draw boxes on a
box plot now we go back to my first
point of isolating the problem because
we know that this bug happens when the
boxes have variable wits but not when
they have uniform widths so I using this
debugging tool look at the data for for
both cases and I can see that for the
uniform width boxes the x-min and x-max
for two boxes at the same position are
the same which makes sense they're the
same size so they're going to extend the
same amount around the place where
they're centered and for the variable
width boxes they're different which also
makes sense because again they're
different sizes so they're going to
extend farther or or less far around
where they're centered so by comparing
these data sets and viewing the code I'm
able to find the source of the bug
because one of the things that collide
does is again send these groups of boxes
to pass dodge to be dodged and it is
doing this on the basis of their X min
value so it treats all boxes that have
the same X min as being at the same
position and so then they get sent to
pass dodge and they get moved from one
another but these variable width boxes
don't have the same X min so collide
doesn't realize that they occupy the
same position so now we know what the
problem is but fixing it is a whole
other kettle of fish and it may or may
not be obvious once you've found the
source of the bug what the fix ought to
be so depending on what it is you may
just have to get in there and start
changing things
I made a lot of minor changes to the
code and saved them with commit messages
like this doesn't fix position dodge but
it might be in the right direction
before I ever got to anything that was
even a plausible solution these are real
commit messages from my git ref log that
I dug up to put on this slide and so I
would go in there make changes run the
rep recs again and see if if anything
was different or if somehow I had fixed
the problem since the main source of the
problem was was that collide was
treating these boxes with different X
mins as not being at the same position
my first thinking was well could it use
their exposition instead because we have
X as a column in the data so maybe we
can just swap that out and everything
will be great so that's roughly what I
did here and at first glance it sort of
works but there's something wrong with
this plot that maybe some of you with
sharp eyes are spotting and that's that
the boxes are not in the right order we
have pink than blue then blue then pink
than blue than pink so that's weird and
not great and then there are some other
problems that are not visible in that
plot but came up in other in other
investigations that this doesn't work
for continuous x axes it only works for
categorical ones for some reason and
then there's this problem where the
boxes are actually not being the
approach to scaling the boxes is not
accurate so when the boxes get move side
to side they need to be shrunk down in
order to fit and hostage is getting them
in groups and scaling them by however
many are in the group so if it gets
three boxes it'll shrink it down so that
the three can fit side-by-side if it
gets one then it may not need to really
scale it down and so you could end up in
a situation where these variable widths
that are supposed to convey meaning in
the plot are not really accurate at all
so this is this is a major problem and
one lesson here is that sometimes in
trying to fix a bug you'll end up
introducing way worse bugs in the
yes so that's why it's important to test
many different scenarios isolating the
problem helped me figure out the cause
but a solution needs to take into
account the real-world complexity of how
the code is used in lots of different
scenarios lots of different types of
data
fortunately ggplot2 has a lot of
automated tests that can alert me if
something that I'm changing you know
causes unexpected changes elsewhere and
as I worked on different possible
solutions I also made sure to add more
tests to make sure that things that I
fixed didn't then get unfixed
accidentally so I then from here kind of
rewrote this dodging algorithm so that
it could see all the data at once
instead of getting these groups of boxes
separately that way it could scale all
the boxes by the same amount and be
consistent in that way and I made some
other tweaks that allowed it to work
with continuous x axes and with these
new changes things are looking pretty
good the original issue was fixed we
have box plots that work with both
continuous and categorical x axes and
then once you have something that's
working for this original example it's
worth seeing if there are ways that you
can generalize it to other situations in
reviewing my work on this box plot
algorithm had Lee pointed out that with
a few minor tweaks we could generalize
the algorithm to handle not just boxes
but also bars and arbitrary rectangles
and I realized that if we did this we
could solve or at least improve three
other existing open issues and so we
could really kind of kill a bunch of
birds with one stone with this or feed a
bunch of birds with one scone so what we
did this the main thing that needed to
be changed in order for the dodging
algorithm to work with arbitrary
rectangles is that this this approach
where we're looking for the x position
is not really going to work anymore
boxes and bars are would be centered
around the same X but for rectangles you
could have overlapping rectangles like
this one in the bottom left plot here
that don't that aren't centered at the
same position but still overlap and
would need to be moved from one another
so rather than basing my determination
of what boxes overlap
on their exposition I wrote a for loop
that compares the start starting point
of one box or rectangle with the ending
point of the previous one so that it can
check if and see if there's overlap in
that way and I should say that Hadley
had suggested this for loop approach
from from the very beginning of my work
on this pull request and for some reason
I repeatedly ignored his suggestion
which in retrospect was extremely
foolish
so another takeaway from the of this for
me has been that if Hadley tells me I
should write a for loop I'm probably
should write a for loop but soon we had
an algorithm that was working well for
boxes bars arbitrary rectangles and from
here it was sort of unclear like when
when do we stop some bugs require only
simple fixes but for more complicated
ones it can be hard to know when you're
really done this new dodging functions
seem to be performing well so again we
want to be testing a representative
variety of different cases to ensure
that it is in fact working before we
stop that's kind of at a minimum but
once it works there still might be more
that one could do to improve it so you
need to weigh the work that it would
take to make it way way better to or a
little bit better to how important it
really is to make the thing that much
better for this for this dodging
algorithm I had started to wonder
whether it could in fact completely
replace the original position dodge I
was really hoping that it would it would
have been really personally satisfying
to kind of wrap everything up with a
nice neat little bow and be able to just
completely replace the old position
algorithm with one that could handle a
few more situations but alas when I
tried this out I found that it still
didn't work for violin plots and dot and
dot plots which also sometimes get
dodged and ggplot so violins which look
like this on the left sorry Hilary
just become slanty lines with position
dodge too so after weeks of work we
decided to just wrap this up and call it
good enough
we solved the original problem and many
others besides and while it would have
felt satisfying to come up with one
comprehensive dodging algorithm that
could do everything we figured that we
can always come back and improve things
later and it wasn't it just wasn't worth
the additional effort that it would take
to to make it completely completely
perfect so we ended with a second
dodging algorithm position dodge - which
is similar but slightly different -
position dodge but can do some things
that position dodge can't now in telling
the story of this pull request I've
really smoothed over a lot of the finer
details and the pain and suffering that
went into getting something that
actually worked in the end but if you
want to see more of the finer details of
discussion you're welcome to read this
if I don't know why you would want to
but hopefully you just get some nice
plots at the end and though I found this
bug pretty challenging at the time it's
really helped me understand and fix
other bugs that I've encountered by
taking this strategy of isolating the
problem with simple clear examples
following the trails of the data through
the code to find the problem messing
around experimenting breaking things and
seeing what happens then testing any fix
in many different scenarios and then
when it makes sense for the problem to
generalize those fixes to handle a
variety of different different possible
cases but always keeping in mind when
the marginal rate of return is not is
too small to be worth it so I like to
thank github user M call who originally
reported this bug which I don't know if
there's any chance this person is here
at the conference but if so I would love
to meet you and how they forgiving the
pull requests and folks for giving me
feedback on this talk thank you
[Applause]
time for questions we have time for one
question while we get Amelia up here
don't ask me why the bottoms up why the
violin plots become slanty lines because
I don't really know
ah the question was how long did this
take from start to finish I'm sorry let
me hand this over it was I think about
three weeks I think about three weeks
and I worked on a few other things at
the time but it was it was a it was a
major presence in my life for about
three weeks I think I don't know I I
could look at the pull request to be
sure but that sounds about right
you
[Music]